- But every once in awhile
the second-hottest girl
is also the first-ugliest girl.
(audience laughing)
But you live by the sword,
you die by the sword.
(audience laughing)
(electronic hip hop music)
Welcome to This is
Not Happening presents
World of Blunder.
If you've never been
to this show before,
this is a bunch of comics
telling fun stories
about real shit that happened.
- [Announcer] Give it
up for Ari Shaffir.
(audience applauding)
- You're gonna hear
a lot of stories
about real degenerate behavior.
I'm most positive.
Comedians are all degens.
We're bad.
We're good people
but we're degens.
We have sex with
questionable people.
We do a lot of drugs.
But we don't start that way.
We don't start that way.
I started like,
as a good person.
I was 28 years old, I'd
had sex with two people.
(audience member laughing)
That's not--
(audience laughing)
Jesus.
I know, whatever.
(audience laughing)
In college when I
was still a virgin,
I would tell all my
friends in college,
I'm like, "Masturbation
feels the same."
(audience laughing)
They're like, "You're an idiot."
I'm like, "You're an idiot,
it's the same thing."
But I was wrong.
(audience laughing)
But there comes this
right of passage
that every LA comedian has
where you really become
like a full comic.
And it's when Bobby Lee
takes you to San Diego.
(audience laughing)
That's when you become
a real comedian.
This was summer of 2001.
I was sleeping, Bobby
Lee called me one day,
and he goes, "Hey what
are you doing right now?"
And I was like, "It's 12:45
on a Wednesday, I'm in bed.
"What should I be doing?"
(audience laughing)
And he goes, "Let's go
to San Diego right now,
"We're gonna go to
this bar and do spots."
And I'm like, "Yeah, sure
I'm in, let's do it."
And he goes, "Oh, also,
we gotta go to Tijuana,
"for um, pills."
(audience laughing)
And I'm like, "Oh, yeah,
okay cool, that's fine."
(audience laughing)
And then he goes, "Also,
you have to drive."
I'm like, "Why do
I have to drive?"
(audience laughing)
And he goes, "Cause
I'm outta pills,
"and I haven't slept
in like three days.
"So it's gonna be dangerous."
So I was like,
"Alright, let's do it."
We drive, it's about a two
hour drive to San Diego.
What we're gonna do is San
Diego, go straight to Tijuana,
get pills, come back,
do spots at night.
San Diego is known
for two things.
Sea World and girls
who love to fuck.
So we're hoping that maybe
we can get the latter
after that show.
It's a shitty spot.
I went up first,
I bombed horribly.
(audience laughing)
I was not a good comedian.
Bobby went up next,
killed, destroyed.
And then after the show,
I'm walking around,
he goes, "Ari, I have these
two girls I'd like you to meet,
"I talked to them, I'm
kinda friendly with them."
I was like, "Were they
here during my set?"
And he goes, "No
they just got here."
I was like, "Oh, how
you doin, Ari Shaffir.
(audience laughing)
"Nice to meet you,
I'm really funny."
(audience laughing)
And we started buying em drinks.
We, Bobby Lee started
buying em drinks.
He wouldn't have any.
Cause he was at the
weird stage of relapse,
you know that where you're like,
"No, I don't drink,
that's ridiculous.
"I'll take a bunch of pills,
but no, there's a line."
But he's better now.
But so we're talking
to these two girls,
it's going pretty well.
There's two of them.
One is like really hot.
Like a San Diego eight.
(audience laughing)
Which is like an
LA, seven or nine,
depending on where
you are in San Diego.
(audience laughing)
But the other one is
disgusting, she's gross.
I describe her face as, "Ugh."
(audience laughing)
And we're all talking, it's fun,
they were researchers at
the Scripps Institute.
Which means they
were intelligent,
which we didn't
care about at all.
(audience laughing)
So it worked out, some point
they go to the bathroom,
and Bobby goes, "Which
one do you want?"
By the way, girls, that's
a normal situation.
(audience laughing)
Just so you know, when
you go to the bathroom,
guys are talking about you as
if you're a slice of pizza.
(audience laughing)
"Which would you like?"
"I don't care."
(audience laughing)
So Bobby wanted the
hot one, I was like,
"Alright, I'll take
the uglier one."
By the way, I have
this general rule.
My general rule of hitting
on people is I never go
for the hottest girl in a group,
I always go for the
second-hottest girl.
Cause the hottest girl
she's got a big head,
everyone's trying with
her, it's too difficult.
Second-hottest girl,
she feels insecure,
swoop right in there.
(audience laughing)
But every once in awhile,
the second-hottest girl
is also the first-ugliest girl.
(audience laughing)
But you live by the sword,
you die by the sword.
(audience laughing)
So I was like, "Alright, I'll
take Uggo McGee over there.
"Let's fucking do it."
So everybody's drunk, except
Bobby, we're all talking,
we're like, oh they
gotta get their bikes,
they chained their bikes
up around the corner.
They gotta get
their bikes first.
So we're like, "Alright
cool, let's get your bikes,
"put em in Bobby's hatchback,
we'll drive to the hotel."
We were sharing a room,
two different beds.
We get to the bikes,
bikes are stolen.
(audience laughing)
Stolen or towed, I don't
know, but either way,
the girls started crying.
Like literally,
tears streaming out,
they were crying.
Which by the way, crying,
that's one of the worst things
for your boner.
(audience laughing)
Unless you're a
rapist, you don't want.
(audience laughing)
Like, I'm not gonna
lube myself with tears.
(audience laughing)
So Bobby goes, "Well how
much were the bikes?"
And the one girl goes, "Mine
was $100, and hers was $200."
And Bobby goes, "Oh hey,
I'm on MadTV, here."
And he just pulled
out four $100 bills.
And he goes, "Will
that take care of it?"
And their tears
climbed up their face.
(audience laughing)
Defying gravity to
go, I literally saw
money buy happiness.
(audience laughing)
We went back to the
room, but it's weird.
I've had sex with two
people at this point,
so it's fucking weird.
I don't know what to do.
There's a guy in the room
with you on a separate bed,
you're with your fucking,
the Ewok on your bed.
(audience laughing)
And you don't know what to do.
So I'm trying, kiss
every once in awhile,
we start making out.
As we're kissing, you just
hear him on the other bed,
going, "Can I just
touch your elbow?
(audience laughing)
"I would like to brush
the back of my hand
"against your shoulder,
would that be alright?"
He's even funny when
he tries to fuck.
So eventually it got too weird.
So Bobby took a bunch of
pillows and the hot girl
and the blankets into this
closet, this walk-in closet.
And he went in
there to separate.
It was a big closet.
And so me and the
girl we hooked up.
And then after about
an hour, Bobby came out
and we drove em back to
their place, $400 in hand,
not for sex, but
it was all fine.
And then Bobby's like,
"Oh, so you got laid, huh?"
I was like, "No I
didn't get laid."
Cause I knew he didn't.
Cause here's what happened,
when he went into the closet,
that girl, the hot girl,
immediately is like,
"I'm too drunk don't touch me."
And she fucking went
against the corner
and Bobby just had to
wait until I was done.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, so he's like,
"I didn't get laid,
"but you did, huh?"
I didn't want to make him
feel bad so I was like,
"No, no we just messed around,
"we just fooled
around a little bit."
And he goes, "You're
lying to me."
I'm like, "No, I would
never lie to you, Bobby."
(audience laughing)
I was lying to him.
But he goes, "I
know you're lying."
And this is how he knew, he
drove us back to the hotel,
he walked me into that closet.
There was like a heating
grate like right there,
looking directly up my bed.
So he's like, "I watched
here, I sat and looked,
"I could see this angle
pretty much, just like."
(audience laughing)
He was like, "I didn't
just see you go,
"I saw you fuck.
"I saw your penis
disappear into a vagina,
"And then reappear,
and then disappear,
"over and over again."
(audience laughing)
And I was like, "Well,
what did you do?"
And he goes "What could I do?
"I just sat there and
watched and masturbated."
(audience laughing)
I'm like, "Yeah, seems fair."
So, anyway, went to sleep.
The next day, we went
to Tijuana to buy pills.
This is how you buy pills
in Tijuana by the way,
you don't need a prescription,
that's ridiculous.
You show your
prescription, they're like,
"I don't know, what do you
want me to do with that?"
(audience laughing)
You just point to
whatever pills you want,
and they just bring
you bottles of those
until you're like, thumbs up.
And they're like,
"Cool, thanks, that was
a nice transaction."
But we got the pills
and then Bobby goes,
"Hey do you want to
go get a prostitute?"
And I was like, "Well
who's gonna pay for that?"
And he goes, "MadTV
will pay for it.
(audience laughing)
"I'm a full cast member now."
And I was like, "Alright."
How much do you guys think
a Tijuana prostitute costs?
How much do you
think, you're close.
- 40 pesos.
- 40 pesos!
You don't value pussy at all!
(audience laughing)
What is that like nine cents?
40 pesos!
No, it does not.
It costs $500.
No, I'm joking it
does not cost $500.
(audience laughing)
This is Mexican girls.
It's $72, that's how
much it costs, $72.
And here's the breakdown,
if you ever wanted to know.
$60 goes to the girl, I don't
know what she does with that.
$11 goes to the
hotel room next door,
and that leaves $1 over,
for which I consider
the worst job in the world,
the Mexican whore-house
clean-up guy.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, for $1 a pop,
he goes room to room,
cleaning up love mess.
(audience laughing)
So my girl didn't
speak any English,
she pointed at a table,
eventually I put money down,
the $80 Bobby gave me, he goes,
"Pre-tip them, they'll
do a lot better for you."
And then, but I couldn't
get a boner at all.
It was super hot, it
was 100 degrees outside,
I'm nervous as shit, she
put this condom on me,
and the only English
she knew, she goes,
"Too much cerveza?"
(audience laughing)
I'm like, "Yeah, I guess so,
I don't know, I only had one.
"I don't think it's that but,
(audience laughing)
"Let's just call it that."
But he paid for it, I didn't
want the money to go to waste,
so I just kinda stuffed.
(audience laughing)
You ever see a magician
pushing a handkerchief
into this fist?
(audience laughing)
And they're kinda like?
Well I used that
technology and I just kinda
shoved it all in there.
And just like, uh,
yep that counts.
Got my money's worth.
And my numbers went up
from two people ever
to four people within 17 hours.
(audience applauding)
And as we were walking back,
we were walking back
across the border,
like gentlemen, with pill
bottles stuffed up our taints,
like real Americans.
And Bobby turns and says,
"Ari, you're now a real comic."
Congratulations.
Thank you everyone.
(audience applauding)
(electronic hip hop music)
That's the episode everybody.
And the season, it's all done.
That's 13 up and 13 down.
Thank you guys
all for tuning in,
for sharing 'em on
Facebook and on Twitter.
Continue to do that.
Without you guys
watching and sharing,
we wouldn't have done
these, so fuck yeah.
Next week, there's
no comment section.
I mean, there is now, but
it won't post anything
cause they'll be no story.
So follow me on
Twitter, @AriShaffir,
don't forget to use the
hashtag, #ThisIsNotHappening,
and click on the Reddit link
to join in the conversation.
Until next season, for
everyone who did a story
for This is Not Happening,
I'm Ari Shaffir,
thank you and sleep
well, America!
And other countries,
too, it's YouTube.
(electronic sounds)